[Music]
Jenny from the block owned in New York
City but which saw on VMAs was just the
start waiting to see what JLo did after
the show so she was on fire meanwhile
Madonna spontaneously combusted I mean
Twitter erupted over her ill-fated
tribute to Aretha Franklin but now today
Madonna's defending herself Aretha
Louise Franklin changed the course of my
life Madonna was ripped apart on social
media after what everyone thought was in
a Reetha tribute turned into a six
minute monologue what we got was a long
long story about Madonna which
incidentally mentioned to ritha Franklin
in passing for a second or two and I
want to thank you Aretha for empowering
all of us check out the gifts a thumbs
down this no no no and another call what
would a rita think Madonna fired back
today
she says MTV asked her to share about
any Aretha connection she had before
presenting video of the year adding
quote I did not intend to do a tribute
to her that would be impossible in two
minutes with all the noise and tinsel of
an award show but here's the thing this
isn't the first time Madonna has been
accused of ruining a tribute Michael
Jackson was born in August 1958 so is I
Michael Jackson grew up in the suburbs
of the Midwest so did I after Michael
Jackson's death Madonna also made this
2009 VMA tribute all about her Michael
Jackson had eight brothers and sisters
so do i and the Material Girl was
slammed for her 2016 tribute to Prince
at the Billboard Music Awards
[Music]
rolling stone contributing editor Joe
Levy says last night was a missed
opportunity she really didn't tell us
that much about Aretha Franklin's
artistry about her music about her
feminism
[Music]